down here in the paddocks formula e  looks and feels a whole lot like Formula  One but there are a few key differences  that we're gonna break down for you  starting with formula 1 is famous toward  roaring engines  formula e sounds more like a  high-pitched hit but electric batteries  are of course silently fueling the car  and because formula e runs on batteries  power drains about halfway through the  race drivers need to literally switch  cars in the pit process it takes about a  minute Formula One drivers stopped only  four new tires a process that takes  three seconds or less as for speed the  formula one leaves everyone in the dust  drivers regularly hit 200-plus miles per  hour formula e cars top out around 160  final difference of fans in Miami we  found a few thousand enthusiastic  formula spectators meanwhile Formula One  is the number one most watched sporting  event in the world remember this is only  year what you got to give formula e of  time to catch up  you